Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一个令人兴奋的消息。如果你曾想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“通往经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode, psychology meets politics. Join us as we chat with a trainee
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由丽莎本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。在今天的节目中，心理学将与政治碰撞。加入我们，与一位正在进行
clinical psychologist on a really exciting placement in the world of Westminster, UK politics. Get ready as we explore the fascinating mashup of policymaking, mental health and a good bit of political drama. Our guest for today gives us the lowdown on the corridors of power and how carving out a placement in such a niche area has become a possibility. I hope you find this intriguing episode about the intersection of psychology and politics so useful. Welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. If you're new to the podcast or to the channel for that matter, please do take a moment to rate and review, like and subscribe. We create incredibly interesting, useful, engaging content
临床心理学实习的学员进行交流，他目前在英国威斯敏斯特政治中心进行着一项非常令人兴奋的实习。准备好探索政策制定、心理健康和政治戏剧性之间迷人的融合吧。我们今天的嘉宾将为我们揭秘权力走廊，以及如何在这样一个利基领域争取到实习机会。希望你觉得这期关于心理学与政治交叉点的节目非常有用。欢迎来到《有抱负的心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。如果你是第一次收听本播客或关注本频道，请花点时间评分、评论、点赞并订阅。我们创作的内容非常有趣、实用且引人入胜，
that helps you be aware of developing trends in psychology and in mental health, and maybe illuminates and explores areas you've not considered before. I'm really excited to bring you today's episode, which is with a trainee clinical psychologist in the third and final year of their placement. It's not your average placement, but it is really, really interesting. I hope you will find it to be so, and I'll look forward to catching up with you on the other side. Just want to welcome along our guest for today, Bradley Powell. Hi, Bradley. Hi, Marianne, and thank you for having me on. It's a pleasure to be here. Oh it's really nice to have you here. I've been so excited looking forward to meeting you.
旨在帮助你了解心理学和心理健康领域的发展趋势，或许还能启发你探索以前从未考虑过的领域。我非常高兴能为你带来今天的节目，嘉宾是一位处于实习期第三年（也是最后一年）的临床心理学实习生。这不是普通的实习，但真的非常、非常有意思。希望你也会有同感，期待在节目后与你交流。首先欢迎我们今天的嘉宾，布拉德利·鲍威尔（Bradley Powell）。你好，布拉德利。你好，玛丽安，谢谢你邀请我。很高兴能来到这里。哦，很高兴你能来。我一直非常期待与你见面。
I first heard about the role that you're doing via reading The Psychologist magazine because I think I saw an article written by your predecessor in your placement but we'll come on to think more about your extra special very exciting very interesting placement in a moment firstly could you tell us a little bit about yourself and what stage of your psychology journey you're at um so i'm currently in my final year of the doctorate at royal holloway and it's quite funny when you ask someone can you tell me a little bit about yourself there was one interview i had previously where i just you know smashed off my career experience and then i thought it was quite a good answer and i got to the end and they said oh but what do you like to do in your free time? But I think really for me I'm in the final year
我第一次听说你所做的这个角色是通过阅读《心理学家》（The Psychologist）杂志，因为我好像看到了你前任实习生写的一篇文章。但关于你这个特别、非常令人兴奋且有趣的实习，我们稍后再深入探讨。首先，你能简单介绍一下你自己，以及你目前处于心理学旅程的哪个阶段吗？嗯，我目前在皇家霍洛威学院（Royal Holloway）攻读博士学位的最后一年。当你问别人“你能简单介绍一下你自己吗”时，这其实挺有趣的。我之前参加过一次面试，当时我滔滔不绝地讲完了我的职业经历，我觉得回答得挺好，结果面试官最后问我：“哦，那你业余时间喜欢做什么？”但对我来说，我确实是在最后一年，
and currently working in parliament. In my first year I was in IAPT or NHS talking therapies and that was a really good experience for me as prior to the doctorate I didn't have that much clinical experience as in delivering therapy. My experience was more as a support worker, as a research assistant, and then working in a kind of like a strategic network. So when I started the doctorate and going into IAPT, it kind of gave me a really good grounding in how to give therapy. But when I did start, I do remember looking around thinking well i've got nothing compared to everyone around here everyone else has been a pwp before and some people have done like a phd or done amazing work as an assistant psychologist whereas my ap role um i didn't
目前在议会工作。第一年我在IAPT（英国国家医疗服务体系的谈话疗法服务）工作，那对我来说是一次非常好的经历，因为在攻读博士之前，我并没有太多临床经验，也就是提供治疗的经验。我的经验更多是作为支持工作者、研究助理，以及在某种战略网络中工作。所以当我开始攻读博士并进入IAPT时，它为我如何提供治疗打下了很好的基础。但刚开始时，我记得我环顾四周心想，比起周围的人我简直一无所有，其他人之前都做过心理健康从业者（PWP），有些人甚至拿过博士学位，或者作为助理心理学家做过很棒的工作，而我的助理心理学家角色，嗯，我并没有
really do clinical work it was more project related stuff um But I think starting anything new, those feelings of kind of like imposter syndrome, I think everyone has them. I actually had it less starting the doctorate compared to when I started in Parliament and being one of the only psychologists in there. I kind of thought, what have I got to add here everyone else has done politics at uni they've been here for years and I felt like a rabbit in the headlights basically. I'm currently doing my thesis as well so that's due in May it's going quite well I think systematic review is basically ready for publication and then powering on powering on with the empirical paper as well. So generally things are going quite well. Of course, I'm looking forward to finishing the doctorate.
真正做过临床工作，更多是与项目相关的事情。但我认为开始任何新事物时，每个人都会有那种“冒名顶替综合征”的感觉。其实比起刚开始在议会工作时，我在开始攻读博士时这种感觉反而少一些，因为我是那里唯一的心理学家之一。我当时想，我能在这里贡献什么？其他人都在大学学过政治，他们在这里待了很多年，我感觉自己就像一只在车灯前惊慌失措的兔子。我目前也在写论文，五月份到期，进展还不错。我想系统综述基本已经准备好发表了，接下来要全力推进实证论文。总的来说，一切进展顺利。当然，我很期待完成博士学位。
I was kind of visualising that a couple of days ago and that gave me quite a positive feeling. So yeah, it's a pleasure to share a bit of my story with you today and your audience too. Oh, thank you. So it sounds like you're almost daring to see to kind of see where you're going and actually by the time this academic year is out you know this chapter of your life will be drawing to a close and you you know I think certainly having been a trainee myself you at some point you just have to get your head down and just keep
前几天我还在想象那个场景，这给了我一种非常积极的感觉。所以，很高兴今天能与你和你的听众分享我的一点故事。哦，谢谢。听起来你几乎敢于去展望未来了，而且到这个学年结束时，你人生中的这一篇章就要画上句号了。你知道，我想作为曾经的实习生，你有时只需要埋头苦干，坚持
going and just keep going but you're kind to get your head down and just keep going and just keep going. But you're kind of lifting your head a little bit and thinking, oh, there is actually a life on the other side of this. Yeah, the thought of having a life on the other side of this. And I do try to maintain a good work-life balance as well. But in the current phase of doing the thesis, that does become a bit more
下去，一直坚持下去。但你现在似乎稍微抬起头来，心想，哦，原来这之后还有生活。是的，想到这之后还有生活。我也确实努力保持良好的工作与生活平衡。但在目前写论文的阶段，这确实变得更加
consuming. But I do like to stick my head above the parapet and see what's going on on the other side. And I think it's quite helpful for me, or it has been throughout the doctor, actually, because my fiance has been a year above me. So she's's qualified I've seen her living the qualified life and I thought yeah could do with a bit of that two psychologists in one house gosh love that I love some existential conversations happening there I'm sure I also loved that when you were speaking about your systematic review you're like yeah that's ready for publication I love that that's like that is taking control like we are we are going we're going ready for publication I love that that's like that is taking control like we are we are going we're going straight to publication will you do that before your Viva is that kind of the plan that's definitely the plan um and I've heard that getting it published
耗费精力。但我喜欢探出头来看看外面发生了什么。我觉得这对我很有帮助，或者说在整个博士期间都很有帮助，因为我的未婚妻比我高一年级。她已经毕业了，我看着她过着合格心理学家的生活，我想，是的，我也需要一点那种生活。家里有两个心理学家，天哪，我喜欢这个。我肯定那里会有很多关于存在主义的对话。我也很喜欢你谈到系统综述时说“是的，准备好发表了”，我喜欢这种掌控感，就像我们正在直接迈向发表。你打算在论文答辩（Viva）之前完成吗？这是计划吗？这绝对是计划，而且我听说在
before the Viva gives you a bit more confidence when you go into it so I think that would be quite a nice feeling but really for me I didn't want to spend all this time doing my thesis and then for it to just sit there if it could be published and for me personally I found once you've written the 12 000 word systematic review you've done the majority of the work you just need to cut it down and submit it and then we can see what their publishers might want changing but um yeah i think for me i've always kind of planned my time in advance so you know months in advance i'll be thinking right this is my time to do this and i try not to go over that i always try to stick to those deadlines and make it happen and so i had it on my radiator October, November, December I plan for each month
答辩前发表论文会让你在答辩时更有信心，所以我觉得那会是一种很好的感觉。但对我个人而言，我不想花这么多时间写论文，如果能发表却让它闲置在那里。我发现一旦你写完了12000字的系统综述，大部分工作就完成了，你只需要精简一下并提交，然后看看出版商可能需要什么修改。嗯，是的，我觉得我一直习惯提前规划时间，所以我会提前几个月想好，这是我做这件事的时间，我尽量不拖延，总是努力遵守截止日期并实现它。所以我把计划贴在暖气片上，十月、十一月、十二月，我为每个月都做了计划，
and sometimes the plan changes but following that template kind of helps. Amazing gosh you're very driven very self-accountable which is incredible I've really enjoyed seeing your name in my diary for months we planned this in like specifically for towards the end of your placement didn't we so that it would kind of be able to reflect on your journey so um lovely shall we have a think about what your placement is like if someone is listening to this and they're like why is psychology involved in politics you know how's that happened? What would your answer to that be? I think that there's two parts to this answer. So the first part is how has this even happened? So when I first started the doctorate, I spent the previous year working for the Psychological
有时计划会变，但遵循那个模板确实有帮助。太棒了，天哪，你非常有动力，非常有自我责任感，这太不可思议了。过去几个月在我的日程表上看到你的名字，我真的很开心。我们是在你实习快结束时专门安排的，对吧？这样你就能回顾你的旅程了。那么，我们来聊聊你的实习是什么样的吧。如果有人听到这里，心想“为什么心理学要参与政治？这是怎么发生的？”你会怎么回答？我觉得这个答案有两部分。第一部分是这到底是怎么发生的？当我刚开始攻读博士时，我花了一年时间为心理专业网络（Psychological Professions Network）工作。我在那里参加了一个关于有抱负的心理学家领导力的会议，当时我完成了爱德华·詹纳（Edward Jenner）项目。在那个会议上，我的导师，也是唯一的心理学家议员，正在会上发言。所以很自然地，在那之后你会做什么？你会建立人脉，介绍自己。我基本上说，如果能和你一起多了解一点议会的情况，那将是非常棒的。我让我的导师和我的课程负责人取得了联系，这促成了这次实习的开始。在某种程度上，这确实只是通过看到机会、产生兴趣并迈出那一步才发生的。但我认为心理学界一直有一种愿望，即我们应该更多地参与政治。
Professions Network. And I was there at a conference talking about leadership for aspiring psychologists after I did the Edward Jenner program and at that conference my supervisor the only psychologist MP was there speaking at the conference so naturally what do you do after that you network you introduce yourself and I basically said it would be fantastic to come and learn a bit more about Parliament with you. And I put my supervisor and my course in touch and that kind of led to the start of this placement coming about. And it was only really through, I guess, seeing the opportunity and being interested and taking that step forward is how it happened in some ways. But I think there has always been a desire in psychology anyway, that we should be more involved in politics.
如果我的导师的选民不认为议会也需要一位心理学家，她就不会被选为政治家。所以我认为心理学家进入议会绝对是有帮助的。对我来说，我真正收获的是学习系统是如何运作的，如何去影响一些政策。作为一名心理学实习生，我认为我们参与政治或学习如何影响政策非常重要。想象一下你正在进行研究项目。也许你正在研究某种健康状况，你发现了一个相当新颖的发现，实际上它不应该只发表在期刊上，它应该改变某种政策。嗯，在这里工作会教你如何去影响那种
And my supervisor wouldn't have been elected as a politician if her constituents didn't think so parliament needed a psychologist too so I think it's definitely helpful for a psychologist to be in um Parliament and for me what I've really got out of it is learning how the system works how to maybe influence some policy and as a training psychologist I think it's really important that we do engage with politics or learn how to influence policy. So imagine you are conducting your research project. Perhaps you could be researching any health condition and you've come up with you've identified quite a novel finding that actually it shouldn't just be published in a journal. This should change some sort of policy. Well, working in here teaches you how maybe you could go about influencing that
政策，无论是给你信心去会见政治家或其他政策制定者，还是提出议会质询，并在政策制定领域建立那种人脉网络来推动变革。这对我们心理学家来说非常重要，因为政府出台的政策会影响我们的服务对象，也会影响我们，所以我们为什么不应该在那个房间里努力做出改变呢？但这并不是我们在本科、硕士或博士阶段学习的内容。但我认为这应该是我们在培训的早期阶段就应该学习的东西。或者仅仅是在通识教育中，你知道，我觉得我从来没有真正被教过
policy, whether it's giving you the confidence to go and meet with a politician or different policymakers or asking parliamentary questions and building up that kind of network in the policy making landscape to affect change and that's really important for us as psychologists because the policies that come out of government impact our service users and they impact us so why on earth should we not be in that room trying to make that difference but it is something that we're not learning about at undergrad or masters or doctorate level. But I would argue that it's something we should learn about from an earlier stage in our training. Or just in our general education, you know, I don't feel like I was ever really taught
关于政治。我觉得自己在政治方面有点迟钝，成长过程中，嗯，我觉得多了解一点，你知道，即使现在在学校里，他们也会让学生在回家前看新闻回顾，我觉得这很有用，因为他们至少能听到对世界上正在发生的事情的、适合儿童理解的解释。而我觉得我们当时没有这样做，我们关掉了新闻回顾，因为觉得很无聊。但他们只是，我认为他们正在让孩子们更加意识到与他们相关的问题。所以，当我们考虑关键绩效指标
about politics. I feel like I've been a bit politics thick really um growing up like um i feel like knowing a bit more you know even now in schools they kind of make them watch news round before they go home and i think that's quite useful because they're at least hearing a child appropriate understanding of what's happening in the world and i just i don't think we did that and we turned news round off because it was boring. But they're just, I think they are making children more aware of the issues that are concerning them. So, you know, when we're thinking about key performance indicators
和实习目标时，我猜在威斯敏斯特的实习与在成人心理健康服务的实习看起来非常不同。你如何规划你在实习结束时希望实现的目标？嗯，这是一个非常好的问题。当然，我不是在处理不同的表现问题或不同的临床模型。我一直在尝试做的一些事情更多是与项目相关的。例如，致力于一项保护“心理学家”头衔的运动，并思考我们如何才能实施这种变革。也许我们可以在这之后聊聊这可能会如何发展。所以
and placement goals for time on placement, I'm guessing a placement in Westminster looks very different than one in an adult mental health service for example. How do you navigate what it is you're hoping to achieve by the time you've finished a placement there? Yeah that's a really good question. So of course I'm not working with different presenting issues or different clinical models. Some of the things that I have been trying to do are more project related. So for example, working on a campaign to protect the psychologist title and thinking about how we could maybe implement that change. So perhaps we can have a conversation after this about how that could pan out. So
规划那场运动，不仅是那场运动，而且实际上是帮助许多想要改变政策的不同利益相关者，无论是与健康还是社会护理相关的。例如，昨天我正在会见一个兽医团体，他们实际上和心理学界有类似的问题，即他们需要修改立法。他们需要增加劳动力，并且正在试图影响议会。所以与不同的游说团体见面，学习如何影响系统，是我在这里发展中非常重要的一部分。还有我们想要参与的研究项目。所以目前，我们正在研究欧洲各国议会中残疾政策的最佳实践，看看是否有任何我们可以借鉴到英国议会的最佳实践倡议。
planning that campaign, and not just that campaign, but actually helping lots of different other stakeholders who want to change a policy, whether it's related to health or social care. So for example, yesterday, I was meeting with a veterinary group who actually have a similar problem to psychology in that they need to change the legislation. They need to have an increase in the workforce and they're trying to influence Parliament. So meeting with different lobbying groups and just learning how to influence the system is something that's quite important for my development here, I'd say. There's also research projects that we want to get involved in. So at the moment, we are looking at best practice in disability policy across European parliaments to see whether there's any best practice initiatives that perhaps we could adopt in the UK Parliament.
比如试图增加在议会工作的残疾人数量，使其更具包容性。这是另一个项目。我的意思是，它确实非常广泛和多样。目前还有一件事是为政治候选人、议会工作人员和议员开发一些表现工作坊。当我和大学开会时，这非常有趣，作为一名心理学家，对我来说，你现在已经把CBT（认知行为疗法）或心理学原则视为理所当然了，然后当你开始和别人谈论它们时，比如我们的想法如何影响我们的感受，进而影响我们的结果，人们会停下来想：“哦，是的，我从来没想过……”
So trying to increase the number of people with disabilities working in Parliament to make it more accessible. That's another project. I mean, it really is quite broad and varied. And another thing at the moment is developing some performance workshops for political candidates, parliamentary staff, and perhaps councillors. And it was quite interesting when I was having the meeting with the university about how, as a psychologist, for me now anyway, you take it for granted about CBT or kind of psychological principles, and then when you start talking to other people about them, about how, for example, our thoughts can influence how we feel and then our results people stop and think oh yeah I've never thought about like never
从来没想过那个，当然那是个问题。所以提供某种表现工作坊并在那里传播心理学信息是我正在做的另一件事。当然，我可能也会在某个时候尝试为英国心理学会（BPS）写一篇文章。请一定要写，我很期待阅读。所以对于那些在YouTube上观看的人，你们会看到当布拉德利告诉我们他正在努力保护“心理学家”这个头衔时，我的脸都亮了，因为这是我非常热衷的事情。对于任何听到这里的人，如果他们想问“你所说的保护‘心理学家’头衔是什么意思？”
thought about that of course that's a an issue so delivering some sort of performance workshops and disseminating psychological information there is another thing that I'm working on and of course I'll probably try and write a article for the BPS at some point too. Please do I'll look forward to reading that so for those who are watching on YouTube you will have seen my face light up when Bradley told us that he was working on trying to protect the title of psychologist so that is something I'm passionate about for anyone that's listening to this that's like what do you mean protect the title of
目前在英国，任何零心理学知识或资格的人自称为“心理学家”是完全合法的，对此没有任何办法。我已经为此抱怨了很长一段时间，但我甚至在过去七天里在社交媒体上采取了非常积极的行动，试图为这场运动激起一些支持。当然，主要是专业合格的心理学家在支持这一点。我相信今天晚些时候我甚至预约了与第四电台（Radio 4）的制片人谈论这个问题。嗯，这必须发生，你知道，这真的必须发生。我之所以认为这必须发生，是因为人们在外面，特别是在
psychologist it's actually currently in the UK totally legal for anybody with zero potentially psychology knowledge or qualifications to call themselves a psychologist and there's nothing that can be done about that and I've been ranting on about it for quite some time but I've taken a very interested effort on social media even within the last seven days of really trying to stir up some support for this campaign of course it's largely professionally qualified psychologists who are getting behind this I do believe later today I even have a chat booked in with a radio 4 producer about this very issue um it needs to happen you know it really needs to happen and my reasoning for why this needs to happen is because um people are out there especially
社交媒体上，有人将心理健康描述为下一个“淘金热”，因为需求太大了。当出现淘金热时，人们会带着淘金盘出去，对吧？感觉这就是“心理学家”这个词正在发生的事情。所以你在TikTok、Instagram或其他任何地方看到人们把自己标榜为心理学家，但当你深入挖掘时，他们可能只有一个心理学学位，而我们知道，那只是基于理论的，并不一定涉及任何临床接触或督导，更没有监管。他们自称为心理学家，并且在道德上他们觉得这很合适。但当然，我们知道公众认为如果有人自称为心理学家，他们就是专业合格的。这就是我眼中的灰色地带。
on social media um somebody's described mental health as being the next gold rush you know because there's such a demand for it and when there's a gold rush people go out there with their pans don't they panning for gold and it feels like that's what's happening with the term psychologist so you get people on tiktok on instagram wherever um punting themselves out there as a psychologist but when you dig um they may have a psychology degree which as we know, is theory based only and doesn't necessarily involve any clinical contact or supervision and certainly no regulation. And they're calling themselves a psychologist and ethically they feel that's appropriate. But of course, what we know is that the general public think that if someone is calling themselves a psychologist, that they mean professionally qualified. And that's where the grey area is for me.
绝对是。这个问题的难点之一在于，那些自称为心理学家的人是出于好意的。好吧，也许存在淘金热的问题，但他们是出于好意的。他们试图帮助别人，但实际上，如果你没有接受过循证方法的培训，也没有经过评估并达到有效的交付水平，那么实际上你可能会造成更大的伤害。嗯，我认为你与第四电台交谈真是太棒了，因为作为心理学家，我们可以希望这种改变发生，但如果公众支持这场运动，推动这种改变的力量将会强大得多。作为一名公众成员，很难找到能够为你提供最佳治疗的合格专业人士，
Absolutely. And one of the hard things about this problem is that the people who do call themselves psychologists are well-meaning. OK, maybe there is the gold rush problem, but they're well-meaning. They're trying to help other people but actually if you're not trained in the evidence-based approach and you haven't been assessed and delivering that to an effective level then actually you could be doing more harm as well um and i think it's fantastic that you're speaking to radio for because as psychologists we can want that change to happen, but really the cause to make that change will be so much more powerful if it's the public behind the campaign. And it's really difficult as a member of the public to find qualified professional who's
当每个人都在推销自己说“我可以治疗这个”时，但实际上他们会用NICE（英国国家卫生与临床优化研究所）推荐的治疗方法来治疗你的问题吗？可能不会。所以我认为我们做这项工作非常重要。当我们与其他国家交谈时，他们对我们没有保护“心理学家”头衔感到非常震惊。所以我认为我们实现这一目标只是时间问题。我们也需要敏感地处理这个问题，因为学术心理学家，即在大学工作的人，自然可能不希望这个头衔被保护，因为他们通过心理学学位、博士学位和研究工作非常努力，而保护这个头衔可能会影响他们自称为
going to provide the best treatment for your care when everyone's marketing themselves as I can treat this, but actually are they going to be treating your problems with the nice recommended treatments probably not so I think it's really important that we do that work and when we speak with other countries they're completely shocked that we don't have the psychologist title protected so I think it's really a matter of time before we make it happen and we need to do it sensitively as well because academic psychologists people who work in universities naturally they may not want the title to be protected because they've worked very hard doing their psychology degree phd and their research and potentially protecting the title could impact on their ability to call themselves
心理学家的能力。但我认为我们不应该让这一点阻止我们尝试保护公众免受这个问题的影响。我相信有办法确保每一位心理学家都能以一种对公众安全且合乎道德的方式被称为心理学家。是的，绝对，我完全同意。而且我喜欢让公众支持你们所做的事情的想法，这样……你知道，我想这可能就像最近发生的关于邮局的运动，你知道，关于地平线丑闻（Horizon scandal），这成为了一场公众运动，公众要求采取行动，
a psychologist but I don't think we should let that stop us from trying to protect the public from this issue and I'm sure there's ways around of actually making sure that every psychologist can be called a psychologist in a way that's safe and ethical for the public. Yeah absolutely I could not agree more and I's safe and ethical for the public yeah absolutely i could not agree more and i love the idea of getting the public behind what you do so that that you know i think it's probably you know it's like the the drama about the post office campaign that happened recently you know um for the horizon scandal this became a public movement the public were demanding that something be done,
不是吗？我认为问题在于目前还没有足够大的案例研究来证明为什么这有问题。我认为随着不受监管、不合格的心理学家越来越多，由于所传播的内容，人们会受到伤害。我很想认为每个人在做的事情背后都有最好的意愿。但我最近看到的一些东西是如此极其不道德且缺乏循证依据，你知道，被动收入产品随之涌现，感觉这主要是为了中饱私囊，而不是真正减轻大众的痛苦。所以我认为这非常棘手。当然，
weren't they? I think the problem is there hasn't been big enough case studies to demonstrate why this is problematic currently. I think the more and more the unregulated, unqualified psychologists go on, there will be harm to people as a result of what is being propagated. And I would love to think that everybody has got the best will behind what they're doing. But some of the stuff I've been watching recently are so wildly unethical and non-evidence based that, you know, the passive income products spring up off the back of that and it feels like it's mainly driven in trying to line their pockets rather than genuinely ease the distress of of the general population so i think it's a very it's very tricky and of course
我们从那些“经验专家”那里得到了很多很多对这场运动的抵制，他们当然也在发布内容。但我仍然认为，总的来说，一个敏感定位、专业合格、受监管、有保险的心理健康专业人士，是你试图改变对自己心理健康的感受时，最好的起点。无论如何，这有点冗长……我只是对此非常热衷，当然这确实是政治性的。我知道澳大利亚和新西兰他们的头衔是受保护的，我想这可能是最近才有的。我不知道我们是否会借鉴其他国家的指导方针和政策？
we get lots and lots of resistance for this movement from experts by experience who are of course putting content out there as well but i still think generally speaking a sensitively positioned professionally qualified regulated insured mental health professional is a best place to start with with anything that you're trying to do to to change the way you feel about your mental health professional is a best place to start with with anything that you're trying to do to to change the way you feel about your mental health anyway this is this is a slightly protracted um I'm just very passionate about this and of course it really is political um I know that Australia and New Zealand their title is protected and I think that's possibly more recent. I don't know if we, do we ever piggyback off other countries' guidance and policies?
布拉德利，这会发生吗？我觉得这很有趣。事实上，我昨晚参加了一个活动。它实际上是关于金融的，以及澳大利亚如何开发了一种非常创新的系统来减少某些金融交易的复杂性。在此基础上，我们正试图在英国实施它，因为它将节省时间和金钱。所以我认为绝对有从其他机构和地方学习并看看我们如何能做得更好的情况。但这也很滑稽，因为在议会工作，
I don't, does that happen, Bradley? I think it's funny. Actually, I was at an event last night. It was actually about finances and how Australia developed a really innovative system for reducing the complexities with certain financial exchanges. And off the back of that, we're trying to implement that in the UK because it will save time and money. So I think that there's definitely a case of learning from other institutions and places and seeing how we can do what we do better. But it is quite funny as well, because working in Parliament,
当我刚开始时，我感觉自己像是在学习一个全新的角色。所以我进来时，没有我的CBT拐杖，也没有我之前的那些基础。当你进入不同的服务部门时，你知道NHS是如何运作的，你知道你会做什么。所以我真的试图让自己沉浸在这个政治议会环境中，吸收所有这些知识。大约两个月后，我收到了一个家庭朋友的消息，他正在试图寻找一位心理学家。他们给我看了他们之前看过的那个人的链接，那个人说他们无法再帮助他们了。不幸的是，这个人并没有为他们所面临的困难提供循证方法。所以我提供了一条短信
when I first started, I kind of felt like I was learning a completely new role. So I came in and I had no, I didn't have my kind of CBT crutch or my, you know, my prior foundations that when you go into a different service, you know how the NHS works, you kind of know what you'll be doing. So I was really trying to immerse myself in this political parliamentary environment and taking in all of this knowledge. And about two months in, I received a message from my family friend who is trying to find a psychologist. And they showed me the link to the person that they had been seeing before who said they could no longer help them. And this person, unfortunately, wasn't really providing the evidence-based approach for the difficulty that they were having. So I kind of provided a text
总结了我认为会有帮助的内容。在我发送之后，那条短信可能有点像一篇论文。它提醒了我，作为一名心理学家并能够分享这些信息是多么幸运。它也让我重新在议会中找到了定位，因为我来到这里不是作为一个有政治背景的人。我是带着临床研究背景来到这里的。我认为这也增加了很多东西。确实如此。而且我认为这可能有助于稍微平息“冒名顶替综合征”，
message summary of what I thought would help. And after I sent it, it was probably a bit of an essay on that text. It kind of reminded me of how lucky I am to actually be trained as a psychologist and to be able to share that information. And it kind of regrounded me in Parliament as well, because I'm coming in here not as someone with a politics background. I'm coming in here with a clinical research background. And I think that adds something so much more as well. It really does. And I think it probably helps quieten down the imposter syndrome a little bit
因为没人期望你作为一个成熟的、老练的政治家进入那里。你知道，你可能在这次实习之前不得不去买西装。这可能不是你衣柜里已经有的东西，不像……但你被视为心理健康专家，这就是你在这里的原因。你知道，你被允许成为该领域的专家，并在其他领域学习和成长。当然，你说得很有趣。所以我的第一天，去进行实习访问，我穿上了我以前用过的最得体的工装。实习日很少穿西装外套。也许我为员工聚会穿过一次。总之，我穿上我的斜纹棉布裤，
because you're not being expected to go in there as a fully fledged established politician. You know, you might well have had to go suit shopping before this placement. This might not have been something that was already in your wardrobe for for this placement like but you are seen as the mental health expert and that's that's why you're there you know and you're allowed to be the expert in that area and learn and grow in others definitely it's funny how you say that. So my first day, going for the placement visit, I get on my smartest work outfit that I would have used previously. Very rarely wear a blazer for a placement day. Maybe I've done that once for a staff party. So anyway, I put on my chinos,
我的漂亮衬衫，我的西装外套，我到了那里，我看到了大本钟，你知道，这是一个非常棒的环境。但后来我环顾四周意识到，啊，其他人都在穿西装。我想我穿得太随意了。所以我认为，穿上西装确实有其道理，它确实让你感觉自己更融入了一些。所以，是的，确实去买了西装
my nice shirt, my blazer, and I get there and I see Big Ben and, you know, it's a fantastic environment to be in. But then I realised looking round, ah, everyone else is in suits. I think I'm underdressed. So I think there's something to be said of, you know, dressing up, wearing the suit. It does make you feel like you fit in a bit more as well. So, yeah, did um go suit shopping
在那之后……但是的，这是一个开始实习的有趣方式。我总是喜欢在任何场合都穿得过于正式，我从不喜欢感觉自己“哦，我搞砸了，我穿着慢跑裤，哦不，这太糟糕了”。好吧，我有太多的问题想问你，在我问你那些稍微有点轻浮、愚蠢的问题之前，你能再给我们举一个你在实习日日常工作的例子吗？在你的实习中，它们都是面对面的实习日吗？是的，它们都是面对面的。所以它可能非常多样化，但让我们举个例子，会议。例如，社会上可能存在人们试图改变的问题。而试图
after that um but yeah it was uh it was a funny funny way to start the placement i always prefer to be overdressed for any occasion i never like to feel like you're like oh i've got this horribly wrong i'm in my joggers oh no no this is terrible um all right so I've got so many questions I want to ask you before I ask you my slightly more flippery silly questions um could you give us another example of kind of something that you do on day to day on placement days are they all in person placement days in your placement yes they're all in person um it's so it could it could be quite varied but let's say as an example um meeting so for example there could be a an issue in society that people are trying to change. And one way of going about trying to
影响这种改变的一种方法是提出议会质询，撰写早期动议（Early Day Motions）。这些是在议会中提高对某个问题认识的事情。所以你可以，我可以会见利益相关者，了解问题，然后起草这个质询，提交给政治家回答。早期动议也是如此。还有一次，我不得不就一个主题写一篇演讲稿，它会被发表。由于我不是该领域的专家，它是被发表的，你还要与利益相关者合作，获取他们对演讲中应该包含什么的看法。那是被发表的，你正在与利益相关者合作，获取他们对演讲中应该包含什么的看法，这对我来说是一个很好的利用
affect that change is to ask parliamentary questions, to write early day motions. And these are things that kind of raise awareness about an issue in parliament. So you could, I could meet with a stakeholder, understand the problem, and then draft this question to be submitted to be answered by a politician. And likewise with early day motions as well. There was another time where I've had to write a speech on a topic that would be delivered and not being an expert in the area, it was delivered and you're working with the stakeholders as well to get their views on what they think should be incorporated in the speech. was delivered in you're working with the stakeholders as well to get their views on what they think should be incorporated in in the speech and that was quite a nice use of my
写作技巧的机会。议会里还有很多活动，所以你知道，每天都有各种各样的活动。但我最近参加的一个我非常喜欢的活动是一个提高意识的活动。当我走进去时，我正在与临床医生和受此状况影响的人交谈。这真的提醒我，作为一名心理学家，你真的可以理解一个人所经历的问题，可能比其他没有临床背景的人更多，或者你能够验证他们所经历的困难，并很容易地建立起这些关系。不是容易，但拥有那种心理学背景是有帮助的
my writing skills really there's also lots of events going on in parliament so you know every every day there's there's all sorts of different events but one of the ones that i went to recently which i really enjoyed was an awareness raising event. And as I went in there, I was speaking with clinicians and people who have been affected by this condition as well. And it really reminded me of, as a psychologist, you really can understand the problems that a person has been through, possibly a bit more than other people without that clinical background, or you're able to validate the kind of difficulties that they have had and build those relationships up quite easily. Not easily, but it's helpful having that kind of psychological background
的。如果你作为选民，你也可以写信给你的议员并与他们取得联系。所以有时选民可能会写信反映某些问题，也许他们在获得NHS预约方面遇到了问题，然后你可以与他们以及相关服务部门联络，试图促成这种改变。这就是我们在这里可以做的更偏向心理学类型的工作。除此之外，有时我的朋友和同事可能想来看看议会，所以我以前给他们做过导游。实际上有一天很有趣，我们坐在上议院，上议院是一个相当令人印象深刻的房间，
there. If you are as a constituent, you could also write to your MP as well and get in touch with them. So sometimes a constituent might write with certain problems, maybe they're having an issue with accessing NHS appointments, and then you can kind of liaise with them and with the relevant service to try and make that change happen and that's more of the psychological type of work that we can do here and outside of that as well sometimes my friends and associates might want to come and see parliament so I've given them tours before and it was quite funny actually on one day we were sat in the house of lords and the lords is um quite an impressive room to sit in um and my friend peers over the balcony because you're kind of out of the way and he goes well that's lord cameron there brad and i go i don't believe you and he goes no no honestly look and it was the first day David Cameron had been made a lord and was delivering his speech so it's really like it's it's really varied the work
而我的朋友从阳台上探出头来，因为你有点被隔开了，他说：“布拉德，那是卡梅伦勋爵（Lord Cameron）。”我说：“我不相信你。”他说：“不，不，真的，看。”那是大卫·卡梅伦（David Cameron）被封为勋爵并发表讲话的第一天。所以我们在这里做的工作确实非常多样化，而且在庄园里走来走去，那种历史感和敬畏感非常强烈。我现在已经有点习惯了，所以能提醒自己能来到这里是多么幸运，这很好。当我走来走去时，我确实收到了一些人的微笑。我想，哦，他们为什么对我微笑？所以，是的，你也会看到很多拥有令人印象深刻职业生涯的人。所以这是一个非常棒的工作场所。我确实感到很幸运。
that we're doing there and it's quite fascinating walking around the estate the kind of sense of history and awe is is really powerful I've become a bit habituated to it now so that's what's nice to do at all and be reminded of how lucky I am to be there. And as I've been walking around, I have had a few smiles from people. And I thought, oh, why are they smiling at me? So, yeah, you see lots of people with impressive careers as well. So it's a really great place to be working. I do feel lucky.
听起来太棒了。听起来你实际上是在见证历史的展开。你知道，这听起来是一个非常棒的工作场所，我确实感到很幸运。听起来太棒了，听起来你实际上是在见证历史的展开，你知道，这听起来是一个非常令人难以置信的特权。这是一个非常受欢迎的实习吗？你必须和别人竞争吗？还是因为你找到了你的导师，所以你是第一个排队的？我不确定。我想作为……我想要求之一是，作为一名心理学实习生，你必须达到，我知道你知道这一点，但你必须在培训结束时达到所有的能力要求。当我开始第一年并见到导师时，实习就开始形成了，我知道我在最后一年想做什么。但这并不一定保证我能获得这个实习机会。但我确实有之前的联系，也有动力去尝试在最后一年之前达到我所有的能力要求。
Sounds amazing. And it sounds like you're actually watching history unfold. You know, it sounds like a really great place to be working I do feel lucky. Sounds amazing and it sounds like you're actually watching history unfold you know it sounds like a really incredible privilege was it a very popular placement did you have to fight people off for it or because you kind of found your supervisor were you first in line? I'm not too sure I think as. I think one of the requirements is, as a training psychologist, you must hit, and I know you know this, but you must hit all of your competencies by the end of training. And as I started my first year and I met the supervisor, and that's when the placement started being formed, I knew exactly what I wanted to be doing in my final year. So that didn't necessarily guarantee that I would be able to do this placement. But I did have that prior connection and the motivation to go out and try and hit all of my competencies before my final year.
我很幸运，真的，在一个能够与一些老年人一起工作的实习中，在我的成人服务中，我能够完成一些其他的实习能力要求，在我的法医实习中也是如此。所以我认为我在实习方面真的很幸运，它配合得很好。但也需要寻找那些机会，并努力实现它，以确保我也达到了所有的能力要求。太棒了。所以你盯着你想要的目标，并确保在到达那里之前已经达到了你的里程碑。我的一个问题是，你去过上议院吗？你去过下议院吗？我想你可能会说“是的，去过很多次”。是的，我去过几次。最近，很难去看的辩论之一是首相质询（Prime Minister's Questions），这自然是最繁忙的，你实际上需要预订门票。
And I was quite lucky, I think, really being in a placement where I was able to work with some older adults in my adult service I was able to work with some of the other competencies in my forensic placement so I think I was really lucky with the placements I was in it aligned well but also looking for those opportunities and trying to make it happen to make sure that I did hit all of my competencies as well. Amazing. So you had your eye on the prize you wanted to get and so made sure that you'd met your milestones before you got there. One of my questions was going to be, have you been in the House of Lords? Have you been in the House of Commons? I think you're like, yeah, loads of times. Yeah, I have been a few times. Recently, one of the hard debates to go and see is Prime Minister's Questions is naturally the busiest one, and you actually need to get to book tickets.
但我最近成功去了。那天剩下一个空位，那是一场相当激烈的辩论。是的。但下议院也有很多历史。所以，例如，如果我在走来走去并做导游时，在走进下议院之前，有一个部分实际上在二战中被炸弹击中过。
But I was able to make it recently. There was one spare seat left on that day, and it was quite an eventful debate. Yeah. But there's so much history in the commons as well. So, for example, if I am walking around and giving a tour, before you walk into the commons, there's a part which was actually hit by a bomb in World War II.
但我最近还是成功去了一次。那天刚好剩下一个空位，那场辩论相当精彩。是的。而且下议院也有着非常深厚的历史。所以，比如我在带人参观时，在走进下议院之前，有一部分区域实际上在二战期间被炸弹击中过。
And rather than completely recreating the archway of this door, they've remade it out of the rubble to represent resilience. So there is history and you do get to see lots of the estate um yeah sounds just so fascinating i'm reading a book that's actually set in world war ii at the moment um it's historical fiction but i think yeah it's just so so interesting so interesting have you met the prime minister i haven't met the prime minister no but um if there's an opportunity to do so then um then that would be fantastic um just um talk rolling back to the house of lords as well when you walk behind the lords actually there's a part in in my little
他们没有完全重建这扇门的拱门，而是用瓦砾重新制作了它，以象征韧性。所以这里有历史，你确实可以看到很多庄园的遗迹。嗯，是的，听起来太迷人了。我目前正在读一本以二战为背景的书，嗯，那是历史小说，但我认为它真的非常非常有趣，非常有趣。你见过首相吗？我没见过首相，没有，但如果以后有机会的话，那会很棒。嗯，回到上议院的话题，当你走到议员们身后时，其实在我的小脚本里有一部分，
script for a tour um where you get in there and you say now just to let you know all those years ago you're now stood on the spot with Guy Fawkes laid the gunpowder and every year before the parliamentary session commences the basement is checked to make sure there's no gunpowder in there as well so um um so that was just another point about the lords and it's very glamorous inside it's more glamorous than the communist chamber actually um and whilst i haven't met the prime minister there was one day when there was lots of paparazzi outside of parliament and i thought this is a bit odd i just rushed into the
是关于参观的，当你进去时，你会说，现在告诉你们，多年前你们现在站的地方就是盖伊·福克斯放置火药的地方。每年在议会会议开始前，地下室都会被检查，以确保里面没有火药。所以，嗯，这是关于上议院的另一点，里面非常华丽，实际上比下议院更华丽。虽然我没见过首相，但有一天议会外有很多狗仔队，我想这有点奇怪，我只是冲进了
office and did some work and it got to lunchtime and I thought oh better get outside get some sunshine when initially when I first started I wasn't leaving the estate I was kind of just doing my work but actually going for a lunchtime walk is something that's quite important to me so I broke the mold and I started building that into my routine and as I left the office I came in through another entrance where there was so many paparazzi here. As I'm walking to the building, someone turns around and goes, whoa. So they mistook me for someone else, but I still made it to the front page of the paper.
办公室做了一些工作，到了午餐时间，我想，哦，最好出去晒晒太阳。起初，当我刚开始工作时，我没有离开庄园，我只是在做我的工作，但实际上午餐时间散步对我来说很重要，所以我打破了常规，开始把它纳入我的日常生活中。当我离开办公室时，我从另一个入口进来，那里有这么多狗仔队。当我走向大楼时，有人转过身说，哇。所以他们把我误认为是别人了，但我还是登上了报纸的头版。
No, I'm joking. I didn't really, but that was quite a funny moment. It's not every day you walk past. You've been papped. Yeah, it's not every day that happens. No, it certainly isn't. And as you were talking, I was thinking, oh, I wonder what the House of Lords smells like, what the House of Commons smells like. Does it smell like leather
不，我在开玩笑。我并没有真的登上头版，但那是一个非常有趣的时刻。不是每天都能走过那里。你被狗仔拍到了。是的，不是每天都会发生这种事。不，当然不是。当你说话的时候，我在想，哦，不知道上议院闻起来是什么味道，下议院闻起来是什么味道。是皮革的味道，
or does it just smell like lots of sweat and people that need a shower? How does it smell? No, well, it's, of course, there's the history within the whole parliamentary estate. There isn't really a distinctive smell, but there are really good services within the whole parliamentary estate there isn't really a distinctive smell but there are really good services within the parliamentary estate lots of restaurants lots of cafes there's even a place you can get your haircut so I actually had a parliamentary haircut recently I didn't ask for you know the politicians cut I kind of went for my usual style so yeah it doesn't have a smell no I didn't not quite but yeah it was yeah there isn't there isn't a smell necessarily but there is a sense of you know there's lots of meetings going on and there's a sense of there's
还是闻起来有很多汗味和需要洗澡的人的味道？闻起来怎么样？不，当然，整个议会庄园里都有历史。并没有什么独特的味道，但整个议会庄园里有非常好的服务，有很多餐馆，很多咖啡馆，甚至还有一个可以理发的地方。所以我最近实际上在议会理了发。我没有要求那种所谓的“政客发型”，我只是选择了我的常规风格。所以，是的，它没有味道，不，并没有。但确实，嗯，没有必然的味道，但有一种感觉，你知道，有很多会议在进行，有一种感觉，
there's lots of stuff happening if anything there's a sense of there's lots of stuff happening. If anything, it's a surprise there isn't smell of, you know, sweat and things like that. Yes, it sounds like really fuzzy, it sounds alive, it sounds vibrant, you know, and it feels a little bit like when you go to an arena venue and there's all those shops and cafes and stuff out just outside that you can kind of so you don't ever need to leave you know it feels like they've created a town in westminster itself definitely and one of the funny things is i didn't actually realize that from one of the buildings there's a tunnel under
有很多事情在发生。如果有的话，这里有一种有很多事情在发生的感觉。如果非要说的话，令人惊讶的是这里没有汗味之类的味道。是的，听起来真的很活跃，听起来生机勃勃，你知道，感觉有点像你去竞技场场馆，外面有所有的商店和咖啡馆，所以你永远不需要离开。你知道，感觉他们自己在威斯敏斯特创造了一个城镇。当然，有趣的事情之一是，我实际上没有意识到从其中一栋建筑里有一条隧道穿过
the road which enables you to get into the more um yeah into the kind of parliamentary estate where the the westminster hall and the commons and the lords is and on that first day when you go under the road and you see the gargoyles and you see the arches it's's, it was, I kind of had to pinch myself in some ways because it was such a, yeah, an amazing experience. And when you do step outside of the estate and you see the London Eye and the river, it's just such a nice place to be working right in central London. So I try to make more of a mindful intention of just taking in the surroundings inside the estate and outside just to really ground myself in that as well so if you like mindfulness I think it's a brilliant place to practice because you could literally spot something new every time you're
马路，这使你能够进入更，嗯，是的，进入那种议会庄园，威斯敏斯特大厅、下议院和上议院所在的地方。在第一天，当你穿过马路，看到滴水嘴兽和拱门时，我不得不掐自己一下，因为这真是一种令人惊叹的体验。当你走出庄园，看到伦敦眼和河流时，在伦敦市中心工作真是个好地方。所以我尽量更有意识地去感受庄园内外的环境，以此来让自己脚踏实地。所以如果你喜欢正念，我认为这是一个练习的好地方，因为你每次走动时，真的可以发现一些新的东西。
walking around it really does sound amazing and it's making me think of the first time I ever got my first badge that said assistant psychologist and I was working for St Andrews Healthcare at the time and they used to give out these really beautiful gold metal badges so you put on your shiny gold metal badge it said assistant psychologist and I just couldn't believe that my swipe card would get me into this incredible building because it was it's in a really really historic building and I'm feeling like the same is true of of you know having a swipe pass that gets you legally into the into this really amazing building full of full of history full of it either past now or unfolding
这听起来真的很棒，让我想起我第一次拿到写着“助理心理学家”的徽章的时候。当时我为圣安德鲁斯医疗保健公司工作，他们过去常发放这些非常漂亮的金色金属徽章。所以你戴上闪亮的金色金属徽章，上面写着“助理心理学家”，我简直不敢相信我的刷卡证能让我进入这座令人难以置信的建筑，因为它是一座非常非常有历史意义的建筑。我觉得拥有一个能合法进入这座充满历史、充满过去或正在展开的惊人建筑的刷卡证，也是同样的道理。
right now it sounds yeah like just lots and lots of pinch me moments it's funny actually when I received my pass and I could walk around on my own and because if you don't have a pass you've just got a visitor's pass you need to be accompanied and I finally got my pass and I thought well I can walk around on my own I'm not sure where I want to go if I'm going to get stopped there's men with guns everywhere men and women with guns and I thought no I just need to go out this way even if I walk the wrong way I'm sure it will be fine and I'm still here to tell the story so that's fine. That's really cool when I started working in a youth prison, I actually wasn't allowed to work there to begin with, because I had to have Ministry of Defence clearance, where they went through every single reference, including my primary school, to check that I was who I said I was, and that there wasn to say that I actually was travelling the world when I was backpacking for six months.
听起来确实有很多让人想掐自己一下的时刻。有趣的是，当我收到我的通行证，可以独自走动时，因为如果你没有通行证，你只有访客证，你需要有人陪同。我终于拿到了通行证，我想，好吧，我可以独自走动了。我不确定我想去哪里，如果我被拦住怎么办？到处都是带枪的男人，带枪的男人和女人。我想，不，我只需要往这边走，即使我走错了路，我相信也没问题，我还能活着讲这个故事，所以没关系。这真的很酷。当我开始在青少年监狱工作时，起初我甚至不被允许在那里工作，因为我必须获得国防部的许可，他们检查了每一个证明人，包括我的小学，以核实我就是我所说的那个人，并且没有，我是说我六个月背包旅行时确实在环游世界。
That literally couldn't be a single gap that wasn't unreferenced. Did they do something similar for Parliament? Or are they a little bit happier for you to float under the radar? No, it's quite an extensive check as well. I remember I shouldn't have been surprised, actually, but it was a bit when I had to fill in this kind of security form, I had to message my parents and find out where they were born and a few extra details. And I thought this is, it's understandable, really. It sounds like you would be able to get in here as well, Marianne, if you ever fancy a change of career, you've already got quite an extensive security clearance by the sounds of it so
那真的不可能有任何没有证明的空白。他们对议会也做了类似的检查吗？还是他们更乐意让你在雷达下浮动？不，这也是相当广泛的检查。我记得我本不应该感到惊讶，实际上，但当我不得不填写这种安全表格时，我确实有点惊讶。我不得不给我的父母发信息，找出他们出生的地方和一些额外的细节。我想这是可以理解的，真的。听起来如果你愿意的话，玛丽安，如果你想换个职业，你也能进这里。听起来你已经有了相当广泛的安全许可，所以
um yeah one step closer bear that in mind for when i'm prime minister um what will be your lasting impression from this placement with you do you think as you consider it now obviously it may change in future that's a really nice question to be asked because for me I always like to think about how would I like to think with the end in mind, what would I like the final outcome to be? And I think in terms of my lasting impression of Parliament, I think it will be one of feeling very fortunate to have had the time working in there to be honest just from knowing how it works and I can imagine in the future visiting London if I move out of London hopefully with a family walking around and thinking oh yeah worked in there let's try and get a tour and it'll be quite an exciting place to to visit as well and one that was quite perhaps formative for me in terms of shaping the way that I want to work
嗯，是的，离目标更近了一步。记住这一点，等我当上首相的时候。你认为这次实习给你留下的最持久的印象是什么？当你现在考虑它时，显然它在未来可能会改变。这是一个非常好的问题，因为对我来说，我总是喜欢思考，我该如何带着目标去思考？我希望最终的结果是什么？我认为就我对议会的持久印象而言，老实说，我会感到非常幸运能有在那里工作的时间。仅仅从了解它的运作方式来看，我可以想象未来如果我搬出伦敦，希望带着家人去伦敦旅游，走在周围，心想，哦，是的，我在那里工作过，让我们试着去参观一下。那也将是一个非常令人兴奋的参观地点，而且对我来说，在塑造我想要的工作方式方面，它可能具有形成性的意义。
as a psychologist as well because it's given me quite a lot of exposure to different areas not just psychology and health but a understanding of different professions and I think there's so much out there which as a psychologist I knew from 16 what I wanted to do and that was kind of my tunnel vision on that goal but actually it's kind of taught me there's so much out there so I feel yeah very fortunate to have had the experience. Oh that's a very humbling end that's really really lovely. Yeah it's just been an absolute pleasure to speak with you and I think people will take many things from what we've spoken about but I think if you are in
作为一名心理学家也是如此，因为它让我接触到了很多不同的领域，不仅仅是心理学和健康，还让我了解了不同的职业。我认为外面有很多东西，作为一名心理学家，我从16岁起就知道我想做什么，那是我的隧道视野，专注于那个目标。但实际上，它教会了我外面有很多东西，所以我感到非常幸运能有这次经历。哦，那是一个非常谦逊的结局，真的很可爱。是的，和你交谈绝对是一种荣幸，我认为人们会从我们谈论的内容中获得很多东西，但我认为如果你正在
a professional qualification where there are optional placements where you can choose what you want to do you don't necessarily have to pick something out of a book like if you know where you want to go you can create that for yourself and I think when I was in training some people even had out of catchment placements all they had to be able to do was evidence that that wasn't available in their locality. And so if people are interested in creating their own placements, I think what you've really nicely demonstrated, that is possible, even if there is no precedent for it. I think it's something that you need to be careful with because of course not everyone can start approaching supervisors. I think that will become quite uncontaining. But I
一个专业资格课程中，有可选的实习机会，你可以选择你想做的事情，你不一定非要从书本上挑选。如果你知道你想去哪里，你可以为自己创造机会。我认为当我在接受培训时，有些人甚至有超出范围的实习，他们所要做的只是证明在他们当地没有这种机会。所以如果人们有兴趣创造自己的实习机会，我认为你已经很好地证明了这是可能的，即使没有先例。我认为你需要小心，因为当然不是每个人都能开始接触主管。我认为那会变得相当难以控制。但我
think like you said, if there's not what you want to do in your area and that you're quite confident that's what you want to go into, then I think there's a strong case for making that happen because I think there's a lot of research which shows where you where you spend your final year placement or research that dictate not dictates but there's a high likelihood of entering working in that place which as I said that out loud I've started thinking about what that means for me not sure if that's where I'll end up in the future, too. Yeah, I'm trying to think what my final year placements were. They were psychodynamic with adults and then systemic solution focus.
认为就像你说的，如果你的地区没有你想做的事情，而且你非常确定那是你想从事的领域，那么我认为有充分的理由让它发生。因为我认为有很多研究表明，你在哪里度过最后一年的实习或研究，会决定——不是决定，但有很高的可能性——进入那个地方工作。当我大声说出这一点时，我开始思考这对意味着什么，不确定那是否是我未来最终会去的地方。是的，我正在努力回想我的最后一年实习是什么。它们是针对成人的心理动力学，然后是系统性解决方案聚焦。
Lifespan service, I would say. But actually, my qualifying job was determined by the fact it was recession and there weren't any jobs. So I ended up in CAMHS for four years, but had a delightful time in doing that. Anyway, I digress. It's been so, so lovely to speak with you. Please do consider coming back and chatting to us when you're qualified so that we can see where you end up and whether you do kind of go further down the political route um you know it'd be fascinating to see the next stage in your journey well yeah so thank you so much for having me marianne and um i think i'm a year-long placement as well so seeing how i've finished the the last couple of months will be helpful i mean unless the election is called early which i
寿命服务，我会这么说。但实际上，我的资格工作是由当时经济衰退、没有工作这一事实决定的。所以我最终在儿童和青少年心理健康服务（CAMHS）工作了四年，但在那里度过了一段愉快的时光。无论如何，我离题了。和你交谈真是太好了。请务必考虑在获得资格后回来和我们聊天，这样我们就能看到你最终去了哪里，以及你是否真的沿着政治路线走得更远。嗯，你知道，看到你旅程的下一个阶段会很迷人。好吧，是的，非常感谢你邀请我，玛丽安。嗯，我想我还有一年的实习期，所以看看我最后几个月是怎么完成的会有所帮助。我的意思是，除非选举提前宣布，这我
think there's's the working assumption apparently is it will be in the second half of this year, it should be therefore a year long placement for me as well. So it would be fantastic to come back and give an update both at the end and in the future as well. So thank you for having me, Marianne. Oh, thank you. I'm wishing you the very best with getting your thesis finished and passing your viva with flying colours i too have heard that getting your systematic review published before your viva is pretty good way to go so yeah wishing you luck with that i think it's your organizational skills that are gonna probably make that happen um you know other methods are also available and are okay too but yeah thank you so much
认为，目前的普遍假设是它将在今年下半年进行，因此对我来说也应该是一年的实习期。所以如果能在结束时和未来回来更新情况，那将是非常棒的。所以谢谢你邀请我，玛丽安。哦，谢谢。祝你顺利完成论文，并以优异的成绩通过答辩。我也听说在答辩前发表系统综述是一个很好的方法，所以祝你好运。我认为是你的组织能力可能会让这一切发生。嗯，你知道，其他方法也是可用的，也可以，但是的，非常感谢你
for your time bradley yeah it's been a pleasure gosh what an absolute privilege to speak with bradley i feel like i've learned so much and i'm so energized and you know i i'm totally gonna try and book in to go and see him and have my own lovely swanky tour of Westminster. You know, he thanked me for what I've been doing these last few years in psychology for aspiring psychologists. And that was, that was humbling. It's lovely. It's lovely to think that what I do is useful to you as my listeners and my viewers. And I would love your thoughts. I would love your thoughts I would love your feedback you know the idea that I'm helping you in any way is just the biggest privilege the biggest pleasure because I know I would have found this sort of content really useful when I was an aspiring psychologist
的时间，布拉德利。是的，这是一种荣幸。天哪，与布拉德利交谈真是一种绝对的特权。我觉得我学到了很多，我感到非常有活力，你知道，我绝对会尝试预约去见他，并进行我自己的可爱、时髦的威斯敏斯特之旅。你知道，他感谢我过去几年在心理学方面为有抱负的心理学家所做的一切。那真是令人谦卑。这很可爱。想到我所做的事情对你们这些听众和观众有用，这很可爱。我很想听听你们的想法。我很想听听你们的想法，我很想得到你们的反馈。你知道，我在任何方面帮助你们的想法就是最大的特权，最大的快乐，因为我知道当我还是一名有抱负的心理学家时，我会发现这类内容非常有用。
heck I find it useful and interesting now you know so yeah thank you for allowing me to keep doing what i do keep gracing your ears and if you're watching on youtube your eyes um with with this content please do consider also the aspiring psychologist collective book the clinical psychologist collective book and of course if it matters to you that people are able to access qualified and regulated therapists mental health professionals please do also bear in mind the brand new book called talking heads which is people's guide to help them find qualified and regulated therapists in the uk if you have got any ideas for future podcast episodes please don't be shy come and connect with me on my socials
天哪，我现在觉得它很有用，很有趣。你知道，所以是的，谢谢你们让我继续做我所做的事情，继续让你们的耳朵，如果你在YouTube上观看的话，还有你们的眼睛，享受这些内容。请也考虑一下《有抱负的心理学家集体》这本书，《临床心理学家集体》这本书。当然，如果人们能够接触到合格和受监管的治疗师、心理健康专业人员对你很重要，请也记住一本名为《Talking Heads》的新书，这是人们寻找英国合格和受监管治疗师的指南。如果你对未来的播客剧集有任何想法，请不要害羞，在我的社交媒体上与我联系。
i am dr mar Marianne Trent everywhere. If you'd like to get involved with the debates about psychologist title being a protected title, please do come and find me on Instagram specifically and LinkedIn, which I am Dr. Marianne Trent in both of those places, of course, too. Love to hear your voice on this. Let's see what we can do, as Bradley suggested, to get the public behind this cause, because that might just be the difference that makes the difference. One of the reasons I do what I do is that I passionately believe in psychology as a professionally qualified profession. I don't want you guys to get to be qualified or to get further along your journey and to feel like it doesn't matter or that others are getting, you know,
我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，到处都是。如果你想参与关于心理学家头衔作为受保护头衔的辩论，请务必在Instagram和LinkedIn上找到我，我在那两个地方当然也是玛丽安·特伦特博士。很想听到你对此的声音。让我们看看我们能做些什么，正如布拉德利所建议的那样，让公众支持这项事业，因为那可能就是带来改变的差异。我做我所做的事情的原因之一是我热衷于相信心理学是一门专业资格职业。我不希望你们这些家伙在获得资格或在旅程中走得更远时，觉得这无关紧要，或者觉得别人正在获得，你知道，
more kudos for what they're doing when they are not at all qualified or experienced, you know. So I care about what you do. I care about you being able to ease the distress of people you work with as well and about you having a long happy healthy career in psychology that's the dream right but I will look forward to catching up with you for our next episode of the podcast which as an mp3 is available from 6am on Mondays and as a YouTube episode you get a little sneaky extra it's usually available on Saturdays so I'm also Dr Marianne Trent on YouTube please do subscribe please do like please do tell your friends take care guys with this podcast that you're sad to be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist podcast with dr marianne trent my name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical
更多的赞誉，而他们根本没有资格或经验。你知道，所以我关心你们所做的事情。我也关心你们能够减轻与你们一起工作的人的痛苦，并关心你们在心理学领域拥有长期、快乐、健康的职业生涯。这就是梦想，对吧？但我期待着在我们的下一集播客中与你们见面，该播客作为MP3文件在周一早上6点提供，作为YouTube剧集，你们会得到一点额外的内容，通常在周六提供。所以我在YouTube上也是玛丽安·特伦特博士，请订阅，请点赞，请告诉你们的朋友。保重，伙计们。在这个播客中，你离获得资格很近了，这是《有抱负的心理学家播客》，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我的名字是贾娜，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床
psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
心理学家集体》这本书，我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，而且没有完美的途径可以成为一名临床心理学家。这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，这会让你感到轻松，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。